I'll keep this brief I've got to get
them to see if they don't communicate
this in will shut its doors I don't know
what it's gonna take to wake you up
you've already lost one of the employees
because you can't get it together you're
starting to resent each other and the
work you're doing I agree but I think
it's hard to come to work knowing the
minute you walk into the door till you
walk out the back door there's a
disagreement in every room you're in it
used to be that we talked things through
we just stopped doing it just been
frustrated frustrated every [ __ ] day
for three years yes you know if you got
so frustrated with me three years ago
that you just stopped talking
it's horrible every [ __ ] time we talk
would turn into an argument and I was
just avoiding the arguments you know
just got [ __ ] fed up we're not
talking three months three years there
was last time either of you stayed here
and see how the guests experience it
through their eyes you can every tenant
it shows can both you come with me
please
there's something in my room I'd like to
show you if Chris and TJ won't listen to
each other maybe they'll listen to the
people who could keep their business
alive please both you take Stan over
there
here we have some guests and I think
you'll find that their feedback
invaluable let's start with you first
the chair and picked up the cushion and
there was some stains on insects on the
windowsills it looks like the windows
have been washed a while we had that
flowers like in here they had like an
inch of dust on that we did not have a
bathroom door we had a wicker like
divider and when you try to pull it Wow
jumping guys I mean I know these are
customers out paying money it's very
disheartening I've never got responses
like this before and I wish I had can I
talk to you about the arrival when you
arrive you hand over your personal
credit card details addresses your cell
numbers what do you think happens to
your details after you've left because
in this book is all of your credit card
details oh here we go this is it this is
the hammer it is vital information of
your credit card details your dresses
your cell numbers in black and white
this is a ticking time bomb how's that
made you feel with everything that's
going on nowadays with the identity
theft and everything like there and that
police at all about them would you be so
kind just to leave me here with the
owners for two minutes please
I appreciate your feedback thank you
guys
you asked me here to come and help but
you both need to change your ways you
won't open up to me and you won't open
up to each other your business is
literally dying because you won't
communicate just like you don't care I
can't even start to move forward because
I'm not feeling the [ __ ] The Hunger
that both you want this place to work so
I'm just saying [ __ ] it sell it I'm
gonna stairs